DOORS WHILE MANY ARE NOT ABLE
TO DO THE SAME AFTER MORE THAN
A YEAR OF CHALLENGES.
JOINING ME NOW IS CHRIS
MONTANA WHO OWNS CRAFT SPIRITS
IN MINNEAPOLIS.
AND BILL ANDERSON OWNER OF
DALE’S DINER AND DALE BARTON
GRILL IN OHIO, WELCOME TO BOTH
OF YOU.
PLEASURE TO BE HERE.
SPECTRA’S ROOM TO A CRITICAL
STAGE IN THE DEREK CHAUVIN
TRIAL IN MINNEAPOLIS BUT I
KNOW YOUR BUSINESS WAS DAMAGE
LAST SUMMER AND THE RIGHTS
FOLLOWING GEORGE FLOYD’S
DEATH.
HOW CONCERNED ARE YOU ABOUT
MORE TROUBLE IN YOUR CITY?
>> I AM CONCERNED TO THINK WE
ARE THE CITY IS ON EDGE.
I DO NOT KNOW THE OUTCOME OF
THE TRIAL ONE WAY OR THE OTHER
IS GOING TO DO MUCH AS FAR AS
HEALING IS CONCERNED.
MY HOPE AT THIS POINT IS THAT
PEOPLE KEEP THEIR COOL AND LET
THE PROCESS PLAY OUT INTO THE
EXTENT THERE ARE PROTESTS WE
HAVE BEEN SUPPORTED IN THE
PAST AND I SUSPECT WE WILL BE
IN THE FUTURE.
>> BILL MEYER YOU HAVE
STRUGGLED TO FIND PEOPLE TO
WORK IN YOUR DINER ARE
ENHANCED UNAPPOINTED BENEFITS
KEEPING FOLKS ON THE COUCH
INSTEAD OF PEELING POTATOES,
BUSSING TABLES AND REFILLING
CUSTOMER COPIES?
>> THAT IS EXACTLY RIGHT
MIKE.
IT’S BEEN BAD FOR THE LAST
SEVERAL MONTHS TO TRY TO
HIRE.
WE ARE DOWN A COUPLE OF
COOKS.
MY WIFE AND I ARE IN THE
KITCHEN COOKING.
I KNEW IT WAS GOING TO KEEP
GOING UNTIL UNEMPLOYMENT ENDED
PROBABLY THE END OF
SEPTEMBER.
THIS KIND OF AN UNSUSTAINABLE
SITUATION FOR US.
WE NEEDED TO HIRE PEOPLE.
USUALLY WE PUT ADS THAT ARE
DIFFERENT MEDIAS AND MAKE IT
TEN -- 12 AND LEAD CHOOSE THE
BEST ONE, SOMETHING CHANGE,
SOMETHING CHANGED ALL THE
SUDDEN LIKE THREE MONTHS AGO.
WE PUT ADS OUT AND WE GET NO
ONE, NO ONE.
IT’S OBVIOUS THEY’RE STAYING
HOME THEY’RE MAKING MORE MONEY
STAYING HOME.
IT IS JUST KILLING OUR
BUSINESS.
IT’S KILLING THOUSANDS OF
BUSINESSES ALL AROUND THE
COUNTRY GRADES BUILT LUMMI
FOLLOW-UP WITH YOUR REAL FAST
THAT.
WHAT’S YOUR MESSAGE TO
LAWMAKERS LAWMAKERS?
>> IT IS PRETTY SIMPLE.
ALL RIGHT, WE’VE GOT A LOT OF
BUSINESSES OUT IN THIS COUNTRY
THAT ARE READY TO OPEN FOGO
READY TO HIRE PEOPLE.
AND THE GOVERNMENT IS
HIJACKING OUR WORKFORCE.
AMEN THEY ARE HIJACKING OUR
WORKFORCE.
WE CANNOT HIRE PEOPLE BECAUSE
THEY ARE PAYING THEM OR TO
STAY HOME.
AND I AM NOT BLAMING THE
PEOPLE, TRUST ME GETTING FREE
MONEY IS KIND OF COOL.
I’VE GOT TO ADMIT IT WOULD BE
FUN BUT IS NOT SUSTAINABLE AND
IT’S NOT RIGHT, OKAY?
THE GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO STOP
PAYING THIS EXTRA 300 OR 500
OR WHATEVER IT IS AND MAKING
IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR US TO HIRE.
ANYWAY CONSEQUENTLY ARE DINER
CLOSED.
I AM SEEING BARS AND
RESTAURANTS ALL OVER THE
TOLEDO AREA CLOSING, REDUCED
HOURS.
ALL FACTORS ALL SECTORS OF THE
ECONOMY ARE BEING EFFECTIVE
SUCH THE BARS AND RESTAURANTS
AND BREWERIES.
EVERYONE IS BEING AFFECTED
HERE.
I’VE GOT A FRIEND WHO HAS A
FOUNDRY IT CANNOT HIRE PEOPLE
AT 30 -- $35 AN HOUR.
>> CHRIS A BIT INTO BRING
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS EVERY
SUNDAY THIS YEAR, HEARING
THEIR STORIES ABOUT DEALING
WITH COVID FOR MORE THAN A
YEAR.
WHEN YOU COMBINE COVID WITH
THE UNREST IN MINNEAPOLIS,
WHAT HAS IT BEEN LIKE TRYING
TO SURVIVE AS A WET BUSINESS
OWNER?
>> I FEEL LIKE I HAVE A RUN
MAYBE THREE OR FOUR DIFFERENT
BUSINESSES IN THE PAST YEAR
END A HALF.
CERTAINLY HAVE TO BE ADAPTABLE.
I’VE WATCHED A NUMBER OF
FRIENDS LOSE THEIR BUSINESSES
IT HAS BEEN TOUGH.
BUT, I FEEL LIKE THERE IS SOME
LIGHT AT THE END OF THE TUNNEL
HERE.
WE HAVE NOT HAD AS MUCH
DIFFICULTY BRING PEOPLE BACK.
THINK ONE OF THE CRITICAL
POINTS IS WHEN PEOPLE WORK
WITH YOU AND FEEL RESPECTED IN
YOUR SPACE AND YOU PAY THEM A
PROPER WAGE WE FOUND PEOPLE
ARE HAPPY TO COME BACK IN.
OUR STAFF IS READY TO GO.
WHEN THEY FEEL LIKE IT’S SAFER
GOING TO REOPENER BAR.
BUT WE ARE STILL PRODUCING OUR
DISTILLERIES STILL WORKING.
I THINK THE FUTURE IS GOING TO
BE GOOD PRETTY THINK WE JUST
NEED TO GET PAST THIS LASSO
BUT WITH COVID PRICE MICK WERE
NEARLY OUT OF TIME CHRIS DON’T
GIVE A SHOUT OUT TO SOME YOUR
LOYAL CUSTOMERS ARE BEING
LOYALTY OR BUSINESS?
>> CUSTOMERS AND COMMUNITY.
WE ARE A TINY LITTLE BUSINESS
IN MANY WAYS WE SHOULD NOT
STILL BE HERE.
WE ARE MASSIVELY
UNDERCAPITALIZED BUT HER
COMMITTEE SUPPORTED SMS WILL
BE SUPPORT THEM.
I THANK EVERYONE WHO’S HELPED
US OUT THERE SOME REALLY TOUGH
TIMES AND THUS PAST YEAR END A
HALF.
>> BILL WHAT ABOUT YOU AND
YOUR CUSTOMERS YOU WANT TO
GIVE THEM SOME PRAISE FOR
BEING LOYALTY?
>> WITH HAD A GREAT RUN TEN
YEARS I’VE GOT TEN YEARS OF
BAR AND GRILL STILL STRONG
OPEN AND RUNNING.
TO DALE’S DINER CUSTOMERS HANG
IN THERE WERE GOING TO TRY TO
OPEN THIS THING UP AGAIN.
SO JUST HANG IN THERE WE WILL
BE BACK.
>> CHRIS MONTANA BILL ANDERSON